سماويه
[موسيقى]
اخبار العرب من غرفتي اخبار الجزيره اهلا
بكم رئيس الوزراء العراقي يتواعد
المسؤولين المقصرين في حريق الحمدانيه
باشد العقوبات ويامر بتفتيش المباني
العامه وقاعات المناسبات والمطاعم
والفنادق وفحص شروط السلامه واجراءات
الوقايه من الحرائق وزاره الصحه توفد
فريقا متخصصا للتعرف على هويات جثث
الضحايا
مع استمرار المعارك بين الجيش وقوات الدعم
السريع في الخرطوم وضواحيها البرهان يكلف
اعضان في مجلس السياده بالاشراف على
الوزارات والهيئات الحكوميه ومسؤول امبي
يقول للجزيره ان الوضع العام في السودان
كارثي وان سته ملايين سوداني يواجهون خطر
المجاعه
بعد نزوح اكثر من نصف سكان كربه رئيس
وزراء مينيا يصف اخلاء اقليم بالتطهير
العرقي واذر بجانتا التايموف بعرقله عمليه
اعاده الادماج لسكان الاقليم وسلطاته ارمن
كهربا تعلن حل نفسها بينما تقول روسيا
انها لا ترى سببا يدعو الارمن للمغادره
شاب مسلم من ذوي الاحتياجات الخاصه في
الهند يفارق الحياه بعدما تعرض للضرب
المبرح على ايدي عدد من الهندوس للاشتباه
بسرقته من طبق طعام الهندسي المقدس واسم
العداله لاصرار احمد يتصدر المنصات وطلب
نشطون بتحقيق العداله للشاب الضحيه
واستنكروا ما تتعرض له الاقليه المسلمه في
البلاد من اضطهاد مستمر الى اللقاء